Netflix società statunitense operante
nella distribuzione via internet di film
serie televisive e altri contenuti di
intrattenimento a pagamento e non sto
per niente leggendo la Wikipedia
una delle cose più [ __ ] di Netflix
Secondo me è che siccome lavora in
diversi paesi del mondo produce anche
serie TV e film originali di quel paese
con produzione appunto interna a quel
paese anche in Italia abbiamo le nostre
serie originali Ma che cosa c'è dietro
un lavoro così grande su una serie TV
originale
andiamo a scoprirlo ci siamo imbucati io
Giampiero ed Ermanno sul set di una
serie TV originale Netflix italiana
chiamategliali che tratta appunto le
vicende scolastiche di questi ragazzi
comunque una serie TV diretta ad un
pubblico giovine e tra l'altro in tutto
sto casino Mi hanno anche fatto fare un
Cameo un Cameo significa non è quello
non c'ho bar per me quando tu fai parte
di una scena tipo come fa stelline i
film della Marvel
però eh Io l'ho fatto meglio Vi faccio
vedere tre ore che leggi cosa cioè sai
cosa fare no
Chiamami Favij
allora So già tutto
Dunque di farvi vedere arredamento
perché l'arredamento impossibile in
genere non c'è perché sono piccoli
però hanno messo questo
[Musica]
un Quadrino piccolissimo di London
comunque Ah c'è anche una farfalla che
crea altre farfalle Wow
[Musica]
primo personaggio che interpretò si
chiama fernandello va in tutti i bar pub
secondo me non paga maifre Insomma
scrocca un po' tutto sono io con un
altro nome sono io però non mi chiamo
Lorenzo ma fernandello
fernandello diventerà anche un ottimo
ballerina Questa era il bel pezzo di
fernandellone
è stata veramente buona dietro di me Non
so se mangiarlo se fa parte del 7
non capisco
e arriva Finalmente il momento di girare
la scena
stop stop
con la camicia verde
no
non pensavo dai per favore dai
Ripartiamo
grazie Era una gag Comunque era riuscito
come DiCaprio è una gang recitata Ma
l'abbiamo recitata talmente bene che ci
avete creduto siamo troppo bravi Allora
io volevo dirti che cioè sto solo
L'interpretazione da proprio colpito
Cioè per me essere qua scusa questa
emozione
Ma questo Raga non ho trovato la
giornata è impegnativa del 1000%
rispetto al mio standard di giornate mio
corpo il mio fisico ha ceduto e sono
caduto in un sonno veramente profondo
metodi alternativi per svegliare Lorenzo
ciclista perché faccio la parte di un
ciclista sostanzialmente Qual è il
discorso il discorso è che i ciclisti
non lo sapevo ma hanno un
una piastra
per il sellino qua no Quindi io mi sento
costantemente
il pacco impresa puoi sederti ovunque e
sembra di avere un cuscino questa cosa è
fenomenale un ciclista che si chiama
Ferdinando di nuovo
fernandello era prima
direi basta cagate e passiamo a fare
cose un po' più serie quindi raccontarvi
un po' più nello specifico che cosa
significa Prendere parte Appunto una
serie TV di Netflix originale parliamo
appunto con i diretti interessati che
sono appunto questi ragazzi che
interpretano i personaggi della serie TV
quindi gli alunni di questa classe
soprattutto giovanissimi attori quindi
chissà come ci si sente proprio ad
essere attori da così giovani secondo me
è una bellissima cosa Ehm
toglie interamente togli per favore per
favore già introducetevi ragazzi insomma
Fatemi capire un secondo di che cosa si
parla questa serie incredibile che state
girando adesso se siete contenti di
girarle poi che errore interpretato
Allora io interpreta Giulio io Monica e
io ieri perfetto la salsa vuota eh
semplicemente sto facendo un po' di Mood
Questo sacco di ragazzi che magari
sognano di fare questa cosa Quindi come
vi sentite a interpretare un ruolo che
tanti come voi Insomma sognano di fare
fondamentalmente alla fine sei mesi fa
era il mio stesso sogno era veramente
pensato di realizzarlo quindi
io ero veramente molto contenta perché
non potevo credere una cosa del genere
dopo un po' ho cominciato a sentirmi a
casa intanto un bel rapporto Comunque
ragazzi bellissimo È commovente volevo
anche piangere tipo Barbara D'Urso però
in questo caso mi sono tenuto un
attimino Tra l'altro sono i ragazzi
super in gamba come avete visto Gli
auguro un sacco di successo il momento
nel quale ci siamo conosciuti era questo
qua Ciao ragazzi oh finalmente arriva
anche la mia scena Ascoltami eh Avrei
bisogno di un microfono perché non me lo
sta mettendo nessuno noto che state
facendo tutto però a me servirebbe
perché io sai nel personaggio importante
Mettimi per favore il microfono qua Ma
tu
Giulio Giulio Giulio Giulio No non sei
Giulia ieri troppo te la pesca hai
bevuto io sono Giulio tu sei eh Mmm mmm
Pietro sei Pietro comunque a parte tutte
le cavolate abbiamo detto è veramente un
grandissimo lavoro il dietro le quinte e
sono contento di scoprire sempre di più
il mondo del cinema perché appunto a me
piace un sacco Fatemi sapere se vi piace
il video del genere perché Potremmo
andare a scoprire appunto altri set
altre curiosità quindi ragazzi ringrazio
Netflix per per l'esperienza se il video
Vi è piaciuto lascia la parola Favij che
tenta di concludere Eh il blog Vai Fabio
la parola ah ah
[Musica]